alles offen weiß nicht darf ich wussten
alle freunde wir sind hier heute weil
diana zuhause hallo die afa und fast
alle sind wieder im studio zur verfügung
stehen hat im rossmann und zwar haben
diana und ich etwas befreien gekauft das
packt reidy auf seinem kanal rosetti und
jana etwas für mich eingekauft dass ich
jetzt gleich auspacken werde und reggie
und ich habe noch was medialer auf
einkaufs diana ich habe hier ein zauber
der panflöte ich zeige es mir ein zauber
der panflöte instrumente sie mein gott
das ist ja super gau oder sogar drauf
singen kann da auch so und ich liebe
dich ist es echt also unfassbar idee
noch diese kleinen dieses kleine technik
gekommen
wenn ich mit einer person die immer wenn
ich irgendwie feiern gehe oder so man
dir ich das immer sehr schnell ein
kleines team und ich reiße sowas wird
kleiner kleiner klappt super ding habe
ich mir schon immer gewünscht auch für
drei wochen 19 uhr komplett empfehlen ja
dann haben wir hier ein
paula fox wachsen von heidi klum und vor
allem es reicht für bis zu 60
anwendungen
mein gott ist das wie weit sich
prinzessin das habt ihr mir gekauft
damit ich spaß beim baden hat dann habe
ich mir diese teile die man meinen
kaffee dabei bekommt den italienischen
cafés oder wenn es gründe monster ja
dann haben wir als nächstes wäre tüte
und es ist sogar eine batterie dabei ja
freude sagt mal wieso hat sie
mitgebracht
eine einnahme für alle situationen alles
super kaputt da mach ich das erstmal
heute reist dass ihr direktkandidat
qualität gegeben
ja gut vorne dann habe ich jetzt auf
jeden fall erstmal neues armband danke
dafür was passiert das machen wir das
fertigen der zwischenzeit hat das
nächste aus und zwar freundlich aber
noch so viele übrig die kleine dann auch
für alles benutzen für interview die
basic danke das ist genau das was ich
mir schon gerochen haben hier die
nächste sache ein medicus shampoo und
dusche
nein noch kein wort wunderschönen dann
haben hier ein sn zone private all
control pad waffe benutzt man das
wendige haut heißt danke ich auf jeden
fall bei euch beiden dass ihr heute
unfassbar viele gedanken gemacht was ich
gebrauchen könnt in meinem leben auch
hier mit den keks
das ist auch weil ich finde dass mal
eben die ganz aussieht sollte gerade aus
wir haben halt hier
was nach dieser woche totale
demonstranten die gewalt warum aber naja
freude so ist das wenn man mal in urlaub
wenn es euch gefallen hat würde ich mich
über eine bewertung freuen dianas kanal
wo wir dianas tasche auspacken es in der
beschreibung verlinkt freddys kanals in
der beschreibung verlinken